i feel like this must be like
the call-in actor waits for what is it
like to
get an audition and offer to join the
marvel cinematic universe
sure i it was a pretty blind
experience i have to say i mean i got an
audition
and the subject line just said something
like audition for
untitled marvel project number four
and the audition scene that i had to
tape
was an approximation of the scene that
you see in the show but with no
identifying details
no real specificity to dig into it was
just a sort of outline version
of what it actually ended up being
and so you know there's not a ton
to dig into there and you do your best
and for some reason i can't remember why
i was on a little bit of a time crunch
and so
it was an audition tape that i made in
my apartment in new york city my best
friend read the other lines
and i had to send it off really fast and
i woke up the next morning
after i had sent it off feeling really
ashamed of myself i felt like it wasn't
good enough
i can be really hard on myself and
i'm working on that but um
thank you so much um life's work
probably
but but i woke up the next day feeling a
little like that was such a great
opportunity
and you might have blown it and
um and you know went
went along with my life and tried to
forget about it and then
about a month later out of the blue i
got an email that said we have an offer
for
untitled marvel project number four
which is a little bit rare usually you
get
some sort of preliminary heads up that
hey you're in the final three for this
thing or we're expecting an
offer we're just not sure when and there
was nothing
i sent that tape i felt terrible about
myself and then about a month
later fully out of the blue um
i got that offer and it was it was
really really exciting
and you know it's always flattering
when someone wants to hire you for their
for their project but it was so shrouded
in mystery still
that um it was funny to feel like i'm
excited
but i'm not 100 sure what exactly i'm
excited about
i don't totally know if this is a film i
don't know if it's a series
i sort of assumed i had been cast in one
division because i did some googling
and um matt shakman who directed that
series runs the geffen playhouse in los
angeles
and i've over the years almost done a
couple plays there
and so the the story i concocted for
myself was that
i made that tape it crossed matt's desk
and he went oh i kind of know who that
is i'll hire him
and um turns out i was dead wrong
it wasn't until i got my script pages
actually that
you know a week or so later maybe i was
emailed the official
materials for this role and i responded
to that person
and just said i'm so sorry is there
anything you can tell me what show this
is
or any are there any details you can
tell me because i truly know
nothing and um they sent me back
you know this is the falcon in the
winter soldier it's being directed by
cary skoglund
um and so it was um a slow
steady process of learning what i had
gotten myself into
were you familiar with any of the of the
world
of uh of this comic book the mythology
anything [ __ ] anything like that
no i was you know
one percent familiar with the marvel
cinematic universe i had seen
black panther which i thought was
amazing
i had seen one of the avengers films in
the theater
because it was really hot in new york
city that day and i wanted to sit in
some air conditioning
and i always i mean i always had a real
appreciation for it when i would see
those
films it's unbelievable what they're
able
to do but i think i felt intimidated by
just how much history there was
and i can be a little bit of a
completist and i don't want to jump in
in the middle on something
and so i think you know i know so many
people during this quarantine time that
have
watched all of the films and series in
order
and i think there's part of me that
maybe felt like you know until i can do
that
why would i go see one of the films when
i don't really know who these characters
are
and um so yeah i was really
not familiar with much of it and so i
was
i felt like i was sort of like
parachuting in to a whole new
acting planet or something wow
and on this new acting planet
because to me you know the scene does
feel not just grounded in comic book
fiction but in like
spy thriller kind of stuff action kind
of stuff
were there any sort of non-comic book
genre touchstones or even performances
that you were drawing from in this
character
that's such a good question um
i don't really think that there were
because i thought the script was so
clear
and rich and gave so much history and
gave so many things to sort of fill out
for myself when he you know he
he um says a lot about what he's been
through
and where he's been and what he's seen
and what he's worked on
and really every one of those little
sentences can send you down a rabbit
hole
of what was that like what did that feel
like
what did um you know what were his
opinions on those people
and um and so i think i mostly just
tried to use that as my guide
and um you know i had i had an acting
teacher when i was really young
say your script is your treasure map and
i think about that all the time and i
think this is such a good example of
that because
really every single thing you can ask
questions about
and and that's so much fun for me
getting ready to shoot something and so
i think i really mostly focused on that
i didn't have
any you know i didn't even know that
i was sort of following in line with
stanley tucci
until i was basically there shooting it
because also it's not a short scene and
so as soon as i i got the
official script pages just a couple days
before i was gonna start shooting
and so i felt like the number one
through ten priorities were just to
memorize
all of that speaking because the last
thing you want when you show up on set
is to be worried about what you're
supposed to say
and so i think i think i felt like i had
my work cut out for me in that
department
and so i didn't have a ton of time to um
you know to even like go watch what
stanley had done
and so when you get to set you've got
the lines memorized you're working with
kari with anthony with sebastian
what is that vibe onset like
does it feel like you're impeding on a
family dinner
or did they welcome you with open arms
what is the vibe like
that's such a good way of putting the
impeding
on a family dinner is such a good way of
putting what it can
feel like to show up you know i've done
a lot of guest starring i've done a lot
of recurring parts doing
two episodes of this thing three
episodes of that thing
and um you never really know what you're
getting yourself into
um you can show up and
the set can be a very tense environment
or you can show up and everyone's having
a blast and
you just never know and a big part of
the work
of being a guest star is just sort of
rolling with whatever
is there and it can feel like
you're jumping on board a moving train
you don't know what the train will look
like or feel like or if the people will
be nice to you
but you sort of have to jump on and try
to not attract too much attention and
behave as if you've been there
all along um and especially with
something
that felt as massive as a marvel show
you could potentially envision a world
in which it
is sort of impersonal and corporate and
just like a big machine
but i'm so happy to report that
really every single person treated me
like i was family
that had been there the whole time there
was no
you know that it really didn't feel for
one second like this is kind of our
thing and
yeah you're here for a couple days but
like it's mainly about us
like they really with open arms
made me feel um made me feel like i was
family
and that you know that does happen from
time to time but it doesn't happen most
of the time
and for it to happen on something so
massive
was really surprising and genuinely
moving to me
and maybe this is true in every line of
work that
the jobs that are special to you are
special because of the people
that are there and this always would
have been an exciting job no matter what
but the reason that it feels special to
me is because
those people are so wonderful and went
so far out of their way
to really make me feel like i was part
of it i was really blown away by it it
was not what i was anticipating
that's wonderful to hear um the scene
itself
you know it's you sebastian anthony and
daniel it's very
intense and yet when i watch it
with your performance there does seem to
be a sense of like
of play of almost like a gallows sense
of humor
it's like a little off the beaten path
for what you might expect from this kind
of scene and i'm curious
if that was something y'all discovered
while rehearsing the scene if there was
a level of like
improvisation spontaneity what was it
like crafting this dynamic with your
scene partners
yeah i think that we had the luxury of
time
and that we shot that sequence over
maybe three or four days i can't totally
remember whereas
most television shows and films would go
it's one location we can slam through
that before lunch
or we can only devote you know
two-thirds of a day to something like
that and so we had the luxury of time
and i think what that really gave us
was the ability to
try a lot of different versions of
dr wilfred nagel and you know we did
takes where he was
very sort of numb and passive we did
takes where he was terrified
of what might be about to happen to him
with these guys
waving guns in his face and throwing him
up against walls
we did versions where he had a little
bit of a sense of humor
um and i feel like
i really give credit to kari and the
editing team
for putting together a performance that
um
yeah i'm so happy to hear you say that
it doesn't just
feel like a person throwing out a bunch
of exposition
you do wanna obviously i'm the actor
playing it
i want it to feel like a full
person and um
a person who has a lot of complex layers
and a history
and um and i think a lot of that again i
think is because we had time
and we weren't rushed and we were able
to go actually
great we have that version why don't we
try something different
or let's see what happens if he responds
to this in this way
and because i really do think your job
as an actor on a tv set or on a film set
is to give your director and your editor
options
it's not useful for them to have five
takes that look the exact same
and so it also was a little bit of a
mystery to me before i saw the episode
you know what exactly will the character
be
in the end and again i think that that
goes back
to the comfort that i felt with those
people
and how welcoming they were
i've heard stories from a lot of other
marvel tv shows and a lot of other
marvel films that
i think a lot of people have that
experience
when working in the mcu and then i think
it's not an
accident that those kinds of atmospheres
create stories that people find
compelling and interesting
and that keep fans coming back for more
and more
because when you're comfortable at work
you're able to do work that is
hopefully interesting and exciting and
um yeah i mean that might be circling
back to your previous question a little
bit
but yeah i i'm the short answer to the
question is that we had time
and that enabled us to play around and
see
feel like we had explored all the
different possibilities
that's wonderful um let's dive a little
bit into the
the treasure map so to speak this the
nuggets of like mcu intrigue in the
script your character went through the
blip he
he turned to friggin dust uh
did you talk about
think about stew on what that could have
felt like
what does it feel like to be blipped
what does it feel like after
did you think about that psychologically
i think the main thing that i thought
about
is what it must feel like to be
so close to achieving
what you think is your highest purpose
and have that disappear
he was so close to accomplishing
what he had worked for for so long
and um and then had to pick right back
up
as soon as he showed up again
and um and i think the
the horror of that and the frustration
of that and the heartbreak of that
is sort of what i focused on in that
because
you know he was the only person on the
planet that we're aware of that was able
to
maybe reconstruct this serum
and um and to feel like you're
dangerously close and have it all ripped
away from you
you know now at the end of hopefully at
the end of this
hardcore lockdown year that we've all
been through
now i feel like my performance might be
a little richer
than i we shot i shot my part of the
series
pre coronavirus and um
it's funny to think about now i really
know what it feels like to
you know be locked in one location for a
long time
and terrified for your life and um
you know maybe now my performance would
be calibrated a little bit differently
or
feel like it's coming from a slightly
deeper place having gone through what
we've all gone through
do you think physically physiologically
that being quinocot in the blip is
similar to quote-unquote being in
quarantine what does it feel like
to to be in this weird thanos dust limbo
yeah i truly i don't know that i have a
great answer i would be so interested to
know
other people's theories and feelings the
quarantine it feels
to me more related to um
dr nagle i think being sort of like
trapped in this shipping
crate lab that is probably also his home
that he feels like he can't leave i do
think he feels like he's under
constant threat or that you know anyone
could find him and kill him at any time
and um and you know those feelings feel
potentially not that different from what
we've all been through
for a little while now so speaking of
constant threat
your character works explicitly with a
figure known as the power broker
i'm going to take a guess and say you
cannot tell me who the power broker is
that's a really good guess also because
i don't know
i was wondering about that they cannot
tell you
in a lot of for a lot of different
reasons i cannot tell you
i'm also not convinced that dr nagle
knows
how interesting i i think it's possible
that someone like the power broker would
communicate
through intermediary sources
or through you know i watched a lot of
homeland in my day
like communicate through various like
you know you'll see a can on this corner
and there will be a message in it or
something like that
i don't know that dr nagle has direct
communication with the power broker
i don't know that anybody does but that
might just be something fun i invented
for myself
in my script analysis well that's
i mean that was something i was
wondering i i kind of had a feeling they
wouldn't
necessarily tell you and i was wondering
what the process
is for an actor to imply
such a kind of loaded emotionally
fraught relationship with someone who
you as a performer literally don't know
who it is but you as a character kind of
need to know who it is what
how do you how do you achieve that
balance yeah i mean i think that when
you're
working with people like kari
and zoe the producer from marvel who was
on set who is wonderful
i think you can really trust that they
will give you all the information you
need and they won't let anything happen
in terms of
like continuity of the performance or
like no ball will be dropped
because they're so thorough and they're
so clear in their vision
and so i do feel like i was able to sort
of
come up with some ideas of my own and
explore
different pathways that felt possible to
me
with the knowledge that no one on this
set is gonna let me
go too far away from what it needs to be
and um and i think also
as an actor
sometimes it's just in your best
interest to decide
that you have everything you need
and i think that i could use the feeling
that i don't totally know who the power
broker is
i have a sense of the stakes of who that
person might be
i have a sense of their impact on my
particular story
but maybe dr wilford nagle doesn't know
who they are either that's interesting
and you know you're a better actor when
you're not acting and so
if i the actor don't totally know
is there a way that the character might
not know either and i think that
you can make a compelling case for that
here
that makes a lot of sense um
you have like kind of a bit of an
action-oriented exit
from the series sure and i am just
curious procedure-wise
and i guess why speaking too
what is it like as an actor to get shot
to fall backward in a chair and then to
get blown the hell
up as an exit on a television show
what an exit i mean if you know if if
the gunshot doesn't kill you
an explosion probably will probably um
and that chair hitting the ground you
know you're concussed at least
sure absolutely right it's a metal floor
so
um yeah i mean
i'm so happy to report that
every single thing felt unbelievably
safe
and i felt like i was in such great
hands with that stunt team
and the effects team um
and so i felt like again it's it's so
rare to have an experience where you
think every single person in
every department is at the top of their
game
and i've done some
stunts on other sets that have not felt
100 great and um
i think unfortunately a lot of actors
have
not exactly horror stories but stories
in which
you don't feel fully comfortable or
stories where something feels like it's
sort of thrown together at the last
minute and you have to
hope for the best and um there was
literally none of that
here again because there's time they had
the time
to not rush
an explosion and really sort of talk
through
when do these guns show up and how
exactly are they fired and when exactly
are they fired and does everybody have
earplugs
and um an amazing thing about working
for
a producer like marvel also is that
they have a long history now of
unbelievably intricate
sequences and
for them someone being shot and an
explosion is actually pretty small
on the scale of the kinds of things that
they've executed beautifully for a long
time
and so again i mean i really feel like i
was able to just
give over and trust all of these people
no matter their department or their job
and that's so i'm so thankful
and i was really um
[Music]
again you you don't you don't know what
you're getting yourself into when you
show up for a couple days to shoot
something
and it was it was just thrilling to me
to get to feel like okay i trust all of
these people so
we'll we'll make it happen and make it
happen you did
um we're just about out of time just one
hail mary question for you we did just
talk at length about how your character
pretty explicitly dies
sure but this is you know it's the mcu
we've got
what if coming up which is all kinds of
alternate realities
comic book continuities can change
is there any chance of dr nagle coming
back in some multiverse as some zombie
has anyone talked to you about that
no one has talked to me about it
certainly
um but i do have hopes and dreams
i you know i think there's no
character actor alive that doesn't love
and look up to someone like stanley
tucci
and so to follow in his footsteps in the
marvel cinematic universe i would love
nothing more than
some sort of encounter with him and
um you know i thought one division was
so amazing and catherine han has been
one of my favorite actors
for decades now and so
some sort of dr wilford nagel and agatha
situation would feel like all my dreams
had come true
so i i have my own fantasies as an actor
but um but i also feel like if this is
the only
time in my career and in my life that i
encountered the marvel cinematic
universe
it was dreamy from top to bottom
and so i'm so thankful and
i never would have anticipated that
something like this
would happen and so i would be
thrilled if there was more but um
you know it's already more than i ever
could have dreamed of
so you know i'm keeping my fingers
crossed
but they've got a lot of characters to
manage
so they've got they've got a few i
suppose
yeah it i mean it's a whole universe so
oh that's why they call it that yeah
good point